D
AFTERNOON. ON THE EVE OF THE
FIFTY SEVENTH MARCH ON
WASHINGTON I WILL SPEAK ABOUT
THE RECENT EVENTS AND CONDUCT
WISCONSIN. THE WILDFIRES RAGING
ACROSS THE CALIFORNIA COAST TO
THE ROCKY MOUNTAINS. THE STORM
WHICH IS WORKING ITS WAY
THROUGH TEXAS LOUISIANA AND THE
GULF COAST. AND MOST OF ALL
ABOUT WHO WE ARE AS A COUNTRY.
WE ARE A NATION THAT AT ITS
BEST LOVES PROTECTS AND HELPS
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS. TODAY WE
SEE PAIN HURT AND DESTRUCTION
IN THE ASHES OF WILDFIRES IN
THE DAMAGE OF HURRICANE LAURA.
WE ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO
CONTINUE FOLLOWING GUIDANCE
FROM YOUR LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO
STAY SAFE AND JOHN I PLEDGE TO
BE THERE FOR THOSE WHOSE LIVES
HAVE BEEN TURNED UPSIDE DOWN.
THOSE WILL NEED HELP FROM
NEIGHBORS STRANGERS AND OUR
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE IT THROUGH.
TO BUILD BACK TO RESTORE YOUR
LINES AND YOUR COMMUNITIES. WE
ALSO SEE PAIN HURT AND
DESTRUCTION IN THE AFTERMATH OF
YET ANOTHER BLACK MAN SHOT BY
POLICE. JACOB BLAKE SHOT SEVEN
TIMES IN THE BACK. IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT IN FRONT OF HIS THREE
YOUNG SONS. SEVEN TIMES IN THE
BACK IN BROAD DAYLIGHT IN FRONT
OF HIS THREE YOUNG SONS. AS
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN PUT IT THE
SHOTS FIRED AT MR BLAKE PIERCED
THE SOUL OF OUR NATION. IT'S
SICKENING TO WATCH. IT'S ALL
TOO FAMILIAR. AND IT MUST END.
THANKFULLY HE IS ALIVE TODAY
BUT HE IS FIGHTING FOR HIS LIFE
AND HE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE. MY
HEART GOES OUT TO THE BLACK
FAMILY AS THEY INDOOR AN ORDEAL
THAT IS TRAGICALLY COMMON IN
OUR COUNTRY. JOHN I SPOKE WITH
THEM YESTERDAY. THEY ARE AND-
GROUP OF PEOPLE WITH
EXTRAORDINARY COURAGE EVEN IN
THEIR PAIN AND THEIR GRIEF EVEN
AS THEY SEEK JUSTICE FOR THEIR
SON. THEY SPOKE ABOUT THE NEED
TO END THE VIOLENCE AND HEAL
OUR NATION. I'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS LIKE THIS WITH
FAR TOO MANY MOTHERS AND
FATHERS. BUT YOU WILL SEE AND
HEAR NO ONE WITH MORE COURAGE
MORE CHARACTER AND MORE MORAL
CLARITY. PEOPLE ARE RIGHTFULLY
ANGRY AND EXHAUSTED AND AFTER
THE MURDERS OF BRIANNA IN
GEORGE AND AMAL LEFT AND SO
MANY OTHERS IT'S NO WONDER
PEOPLE ARE TAKEN TO THE STREETS.
AND I SUPPORT THEM. WE MUST
ALWAYS DEFEND PEACEFUL PROTEST
AND PEACEFUL PROTESTERS. WE
SHOULD NOT CONFUSE THEM WITH
THOSE LOOTING AND COMMITTING
ACTS OF VIOLENCE INCLUDING THE
SHOOTER WHO WAS ARRESTED FOR
MURDER. AND MAKE NO MISTAKE WE
WILL NOT LET THESE VIGILANTE IS
AN EXTREMIST. DERAIL THE PATH
TO JUSTICE. HERE'S MY PROMISE
TO THOSE MOTHERS AND FATHERS
AND ALL WHO STAND WITH THEM. IN
A BIDEN HERIS ADMINISTRATION
YOU WILL HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE. IN THE HALLS OF CONGRESS
AND IN THE WHITE HOUSE. WE ALL
GREW UP RECITING THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. BUT NOW. WE MUST
GIVE REAL MEANING TO ITS WORDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. JUSTICE LET'S
TALK ABOUT THEM. BECAUSE THE
REALITY IS THAT THE LIFE OF A
BLACK PERSON IN AMERICA HAS
NEVER BEEN TREATED AS FULLY
HUMAN. AND WE HAVE YET TO
FULFILL THAT PROMISE. OF EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER LAW. WE WILL ONLY
ACHIEVE THAT WHEN WE FINALLY
COME TOGETHER TO PASS
MEANINGFUL POLICE REFORM AND
BROADER CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
AND ACKNOWLEDGE. YES IT
KNOWLEDGE AND ADDRESS SYSTEMIC
RACISM. WE WILL ONLY COME
CLOSER TO ACHIEVING THAT WHEN
WE FINALLY COME TOGETHER. WE
HAVE COME A LONG WAY IN OUR
COUNTRY TOWARDS BUILDING A MORE
PERFECT UNION. AND THE TIME IS
NOW RIGHT NOW. TO TAKE THE NEXT
STEP FORWARD. AND EVEN AS WE
EXPERIENCE THIS RECKONING WITH
RACIAL INJUSTICE WE MUST ALSO
CONFRONT ANOTHER CRISIS. THE
PANDEMIC THAT HAS TORN APART SO
MANY LINES. THE NUMBERS THAT
DEFINED THIS CRISIS ARE
STAGGERING. WE CANNOT LOOK THE
OTHER WAY OR ALLOW OURSELVES TO
BECOME NUMB TO THEM. NEARLY SIX
MILLION CONFIRMED CASES. OF THE
CORONAVIRUS ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND LIVES LOST MORE
THAN FIFTY MILLION CLAIMS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT THIS YEAR ALONE.
WE NEED TO SEE AND WE NEED TO
HEAR WHAT IS HAPPENING IN OUR
COUNTRY. THE QUIET DESPERATION
THAT HAS TAKEN OVER SO MANY
LIVES IN AMERICA. THE FAMILY
PACKING INTO THEIR CAR AT FIVE
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING HOPING
THE LOCAL FOOD BANK STILL HAS
SOMETHING LEFT WHEN THEY GET TO
THE FRONT OF THE LINE. THE
FIFTY YEAR OLD STORE MANAGER.
WAS BEEN LAID OFF AND KNOWS HE
CAN'T PAY THE RENT ON THE FIRST
OF THE MONTH. THE MOTHERS AND
FATHERS STRETCHED TO THE
BREAKING POINT WORKING FROM
HOME WHILE HELPING THEIR KIDS
WITH THEIR ONLINE CLASSES. JUST
TRYING TO HOLD IT ALL TOGETHER.
THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
ECONOMIC ENGINES OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE SHUTTING
THEIR DOORS EVERY DAY. THE
NURSE GETTING READY FOR HER
AFTERNOON SHIFT WHO HAS SEEN SO
MUCH SUFFERING AND DEATH IN
RECENT MONTHS AND WONDERS HOW
MUCH MORE CAN SHE BEAR TO
WITNESS. THE FAMILY GRIEVING
THE LOSS OF THEIR GRANDMOTHER.
WHO'S BEEN IN A NURSING HOME
AND WHO THEY COULDN'T EVEN
VISIT OVER THE LAST THREE
MONTHS OF HER LIFE. THE
ALARMING AND DISPROPORTIONATE
RATE. AT WHICH BLACK LATINO
INDEED AN INDIGENOUS FAMILIES
ARE CONTRACTING AND DYING OF
COVID NINETEEN. THAT IS THE
REALITY OF AMERICA RIGHT NOW. A
REALITY COMPLETELY ABSENT FROM
THIS WEEK'S REPUBLICAN NATIONAL
CONVENTION. BECAUSE UNLIKE THE
DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION WHICH WAS
VERY CLEAR EYED ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES WE ARE FACING AND
HOW WE WILL TACKLE THEM. THE
REPUBLICAN CONVENTION IS
DESIGNED FOR ONE PURPOSE. TO
SUE DONALD TRUMP'S EGO. TO MAKE
HIM FEEL GOOD. BUT HERE'S THE
THING. HE'S THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES. AND IT'S NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT HIM. IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT THE HEALTH
AND THE SAFETY AND THE WELL
BEING OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND ON THAT MEASURE DONALD
TRUMP HAS FAILED. YOU SEE AT
ITS MOST BASIC LEVEL. DONALD
TRUMP DOESN'T UNDERSTAND THE
PRESIDENCY. HE THINKS IT'S ALL
ABOUT HIM. WELL IT'S NOT IT'S
ABOUT YOU. IT'S ABOUT ALL OF US.
THE PEOPLE. AS A LAWYER AND
ADVOCATE WHEN I WOULD RISE TO
SPEAK IN THE COURT ROOM I'D SAY
THE FOLLOWING WORDS. KAMILLA
HARRIS FOR THE PEOPLE. AND THAT
IS WHY I STAND TODAY TO SPEAK
FOR THE PEOPLE. BECAUSE WE KNOW
THE TRUTH. DONALD TRUMP HAS
FAILED AT THE MOST BASIC AND
IMPORTANT JOB OF A PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES. HE FAILED TO
PROTECT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PLAIN AND SIMPLE TRUMP SHOWED
THAT WE IN THE LEGAL PROFESSION
WOULD CALL A RECKLESS DISREGARD
FOR THE WELL BEING OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. A RECKLESS
DISREGARD FOR THE DANGER OF
PANDEMIC WOULD POSE TO AMERICAN
LINES. FOR THE DEVASTATION IT
WOULD DO TO OUR ECONOMY. BUT
THE DAMAGE IT WOULD DO TO
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO HAVE
BEEN SUBJECTED TO STRUCTURAL
RACISM FOR GENERATIONS. THE
CHAOS THAT WOULD UPEND OUR
DAILY LINES MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE
FOR MANY OF OUR CHILDREN TO GO
TO SCHOOL. MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE
TO LIVE NORMALLY AND WITH THE
SENSE OF CERTAINTY. HE NEVER
APPRECIATED AT A PRESIDENT
SWEARS AN OATH BEFORE GOD AND
COUNTRY TO PROTECT AMERICA
AGAINST THREATS SEEN AND UNSEEN.
IT'S HIS DUTY. IT'S A OUR
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT US. AND
YET HE HAS FAILED. MISERABLY.
HERE'S THE THING. DONALD
TRUMP'S INCOMPETENCE IS NOTHING
NEW. THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN ON
FULL DISPLAY. BUT IN JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR IT BECAME DEADLY.
THAT'S WHEN THE THREAT OF A
VIRUS THAT IT WOULD ENDANGER
THE WORLD'S FIRST EMERGED.
TRUMP DISMISSED THE THREAT. BUT
JOE BIDEN SOUND THE ALARM. IT
WOULD BE THE BEGINNING OF A
PATTERN THAT PERSIST TO THIS
DAY. TRUMP TELLING US NOT TO
WORRY THAT THE VIRUS WILL QUOTE
DISAPPEAR THAT A QUOTE MIRACLE
IS COMING. JOE BIDEN SAYING WE
NEED A PLAN A NATIONAL STRATEGY.
A PRESIDENT WHO IS WILLING TO
LEAD WILLING TO BE A ROLE MODEL
FOR OUR NATION. FOR OUR
CHILDREN. TRUMP STILL DOESN'T
HAVE A PLAN HE STILL DOESN'T
HAVE A PLAN. JOE BIDEN RELEASED
HIS FIRST PLAN IN MARCH. AND
HERE'S WHAT YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND ABOUT THE NATURE OF
A PANDEMIC. IT'S RELENTLESS YOU
CAN'T STOP IT WITH THE TWEET.
YOU CAN'T CREATE A DISTRACTION
AND HOPE IT'LL GO AWAY. IT
DOESN'T GO AWAY. BY ITS NATURE
A PANDEMIC IS UNFORGIVING. IF
YOU GET IT WRONG AT THE
BEGINNING THE CONSEQUENCES. OUR
CATASTROPHIC. AND IT'S VERY
HARD TO CATCH UP YOU DON'T GET
A SECOND CHANCE AT GETTING IT
RIGHT. WELL PRESIDENT TRUMP HE
GOT IT WRONG FROM THE BEGINNING.
AND THEN HE GOT IT WRONG AGAIN
AND AGAIN. AND THE CONSEQUENCES
HAVE BEEN CATASTROPHIC. AND
HERE'S WHY TRUMP HAS BEEN SO
UNWILLING AND I'M ABLE TO DEAL
WITH THIS CRISIS. FIRST HE WAS
FIXATED ON THE STOCK MARKET
OVER FIXING THE PROBLEM. HE
TWEETED ABOUT IT CONSISTENTLY
DURING THIS PERIOD. HE WAS
CONVINCED THAT IS IF HIS
ADMINISTRATION FOCUSED ON THIS
VIRUS IT WOULD HURT THE MARKET
AND HURT HIS CHANCES OF BEING
REELECTED. THAT MATTERED TO HIM
MORE THAN SAVING AMERICAN LIVES.
SECOND RIGHT AT THE MOMENT THAT
WE NEEDED DONALD TRUMP TO BE
TOUGH ON THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
HE CAVED. ON TWENTY JANUARY
TWENTY FOURTH HE PRAISED THE
TRANSPARENCY OF THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT HE SAID QUOTE. CHINA
HAS BEEN WORKING HARD TO
CONTAIN THE CORONAVIRUS THE
UNITED STATES GREATLY
APPRECIATES THEIR EFFORTS AND
TRANSPARENCY IT WILL ALL WORK
OUT WELL. BUT THEY WEREN'T
BEING TRANSPARENT. THEY BLOCKED
PUBLIC HEALTH INSPECTORS FROM
OUR CDC FROM GETTING ACCESS AND
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEEDED TO
PROTECT AMERICAN LIVES. DONALD
TRUMP STOOD IDLY BY. AND FOLKS
IT WAS A DEADLY DECISION.
INSTEAD OF RISING TO MEET THE
MOST DIFFICULT MOMENT OF HIS
PRESIDENCY. DONALD TRUMP THROWS.
HE WAS SCARED. AND HE WAS PETTY
AND VINDICTIVE. ON A CALL WITH
GOVERNORS ACROSS THE COUNTRY ON
MARCH SIXTEENTH HE TOLD THEM IT
WASN'T HIS JOB TO GET PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT TO
FRONTLINE WORKERS HE SAID QUOTE.
RESPIRATORS VENTILATORS ALL OF
THE EQUIPMENT TRY GETTING IT
YOURSELVES UNQUOTE. ON THAT DAY
WE HAD ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND
CASES AS A NATION. TODAY WE
HAVE NEARLY SIX MILLION. EVEN
NOW SOME EIGHT MONTHS INTO THIS
CRISIS DONALD TRUMP STILL WON'T
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY HE STILL
WON'T ACT. AND THE TRAGEDY IN
ALL OF THIS. IS IT DIDN'T HAVE
TO BE THIS BAD. JUST LOOK
AROUND IT'S NOT LIKE THIS AND
THE REST OF THE WORLD. ALL WE
NEEDED. GUYS ALL WE NEEDED WAS
A COMPETENT PRESIDENT. ONE WAS
WILLING TO LISTEN. WILLING TO
LEAD TAKE RESPONSIBILITY HAVE A
PLAN. DO THEIR JOB. WELL JOE
BIDEN WILL BE THAT PRESIDENT.
IT'S GOT A NATIONAL STRATEGY
HE'S MORE THAN READY TO LEAVE.
EVERY MONTH SINCE MARCH AS THIS
PANDEMIC IS UNFOLDED JOE BIDEN
HAS UPDATED THE STEPS HE WOULD
TAKE TO SAVE AMERICAN LIVES.
AND HE'S DONE IT BASED ON WHAT
EVERY SO. EVERY EXPERT EVERY
ECONOMIST SAID WE SHOULD BE
DOING. AS PRESIDENT. JOE BIDEN
WE'LL PUT A PLAN INTO EFFECT ON
DAY ONE. DEVELOP AND DEPLOY
RAPID TEST WITH IMMEDIATE
RESULTS MAKE SURE TESTING
TREATMENTS AND ULTIMATELY A
VACCINE REACH ALL AMERICANS
INCLUDING COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
WHO HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN LEFT
BEHIND. MANUFACTURE THE MEDICAL
SUPPLIES AND PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT WE NEED. AND MAKE
THEM RIGHT HERE IN AMERICA SO
WE'RE NEVER AGAIN AT THE MERCY
OF CHINA AND OTHER FOREIGN
COUNTRIES TO PROTECT OUR OWN
PEOPLE. JOHN I WILL MAKE SURE
OUR SCHOOLS HAVE ALL THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO BE OPEN
AND SAFE AND EFFECTIVE. PUT
POLITICS ASIDE AND NOT SILENCE
THE EXPERTS SO THE PUBLIC GETS
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED AND
DESERVE. AND PUT IN PLACE A
NATION WIDE MASK MANDATE.
BECAUSE IN JOE'S WORDS IT'S NOT
A BURDEN TO PROTECT EACH OTHER.
AND HE SAYS THAT BECAUSE THE
THING ABOUT JOE IS HE KNOWS
WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
DONALD TRUMP SAYS THERE'S
NOTHING HE COULD HAVE DONE TO
PREVENT ALL THIS DEATH. HERE'S
THE TRUTH. BARACK OBAMA AND JOE
BIDEN HAD A PROGRAM CALLED
PROJECT. THAT TRACK EMERGING.
DISEASES IN PLACES LIKE CHINA.
I'M GONNA REPEAT THAT. THE
PROGRAM TRACKED EMERGING
DISEASES IN PLACES LIKE CHINA.
TRUMP CUT IT. THEY DETECTED A
TEAM AND CREATED THAT TEAM IN
THE NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
TO GLOBAL HEALTH AND SECURITY
DEDICATING THEM TO THE WORK OF
GLOBAL HEALTH AND SECURITY AND
BIODEFENSE. DONALD TRUMP
ELIMINATED IT. THEY IMPLEMENTED
STANDARDS FOR NURSING HOMES TO
IMPROVE INFECTION CONTROL.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE RACING THEM.
BEFORE THE VIRUS HIT TRUMP MADE
OUR COUNTRY VULNERABLE. AFTER
IT WAS STRUCK HE FAILED TO DO
WHAT WAS NECESSARY. AS IT
CONTINUES HE'S MAKING IT WORSE
EVERY DAY. JUST THIS WEEK JUST
THIS WEEK THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION SAID A CUT TO
SOCIAL SECURITY LIKE THE ONE
TRUMP IS PROPOSING WOULD AND
DISABILITY BENEFITS WITHIN ONE
YEAR. AND ALL BENEFITS WITHIN
THREE YEARS. SO LET ME BE AS
CLEAR AS POSSIBLE. IF DONALD
TRUMP'S EXTREME PROPOSAL GOES
INTO EFFECT THE CHECKS THAT
AMERICAN SENIORS ARE RELYING
ON. THAT YOU RELY ON TO PAY
YOUR BILLS TO BUY YOUR
MEDICINE. TO LIVE. STOP COMING.
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SUFFERED SO GREATLY IN THIS
CRISIS. IT'S UNTHINKABLE. AND
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE HEALTH
CRISIS MADE WORSE BY HIS OWN
ACTIONS. DONALD TRUMP IS IN
COURT RIGHT NOW. TRYING TO
THROW OUT THE ENTIRE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT INCLUDING THE
PROTECTIONS IT PROVIDES FOR
PEOPLE WITH PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS. SO THAT MEANS IF
YOU ARE FORTUNATE. ENOUGH TO
SURVIVE COVID NINETEEN INSURERS
COULD DENY YOU COVERAGE FOR
TREATING ANY LONG TERM EFFECTS.
NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP WON'T TELL
YOU ANY OF THIS AT THE
REPUBLICAN CONVENTION TONIGHT.
AND WE ALL KNOW. HE'S NOT
CHANGING. THE PRESIDENT HE HAS
BEEN IS THE PRESIDENT HE WILL
BE. BUT WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
RIGHT THESE WRONGS AND PUT
AMERICA ON A BETTER PATH
FORWARD. ONE WHERE THE LEADERS
WE ELECT LISTEN TO THE EXPERTS
AND FOLLOW THE BEST MEDICAL
GUIDANCE TO KEEP US AND OUR
FAMILIES HEALTHY AND SAFE. ONE
WHERE WE TAKE MEANINGFUL ACTION
AGAINST SYSTEMS AND TRADITIONS
OF OPPRESSION. ONE WHERE WE
STOP FANNING THE FLAMES OF HATE
AND DIVISION AND TREAT ONE
ANOTHER WITH THE RESPECT AND
THE DIGNITY THAT EACH ONE OF US
DESERVES. AS JOE BIDEN SAID IN
HIS ACCEPTANCE SPEECH. WE HAVE
A CHOICE. BETWEEN THE LIGHT AND
THE DARK. I BELIEVE AMERICA
WILL CHOOSE THE LIGHT. THANK
YOU. AFTER THE SHOT GARTH.